with games like red dead redemption LA
noire and of course grand theft auto
it's easy to forget about some of
rockstars other projects especially when
one of those projects was announced way
back in 2007 and we've still almost seen
nothing for it if you haven't figured it
out by now the game I'm referring to his
agent and since its announcement in 2007
we haven't really seen anything from it
apart from some images that were leaked
back in 2011 today some more images of
the game setting have emerged online as
i'm sure you can tell these images look
somewhat dated but that's to be expected
considering the game was originally
supposed to come out as a playstation 3
exclusive these images are apparently
derived from a half decade old version
of the game if this batch of agent
images is any indication the game would
have at least partially been set in a
mountainside city the image is
reportedly stem from someone who is
working on the game until his team
shifted to grand theft auto 5 agent
which is set in the 1970s was first
revealed in 2007 and later detailed at
the 2009 Electronic Entertainment Expo
when the game does ship it will do so
with high expectations in 2009 former
take to President Ben fetter told
GameSpot that agent is being groomed to
be the next Grand Theft Auto he said
it's the 18 working on a triple a title
I think the subject matter the
characters the story the environment the
background all the elements are there
it's such a rich environment to plan
it's rare that we see behind the curtain
of a rock star game but after eight
years I'm surprised they haven't called
it quits on the game for more on agent
if and when it comes you're already in
the right place